you know I'm accustomed to you just as
my sort of co-host yeah on the program
but thanks for hanging out and doing Q&A
well I appreciate this man because I'm
bringing them to life I am and I'm
actually learning something too huh
I got it you're like the Bill Cosby of
science you know a stock dog radio
Wow you better be careful you might
learn something before it's done you see
okay okay so uh speaking of learning
something okay here's John Rowe with a
question all right I believe this is
from Facebook John says how valid are
the assumptions made in the Drake
Equation is it outdated what would be
the equation today what would it be like
given new parameters with the knowledge
of today and then he says Thanks here's
what I got to say John what the hell is
the very quaint okay so clearly our
questioners are more scientifically
literate than you chuck this is true all
right so so for Chuck and others who
might not know about the Drake Equation
there's a guy named Frank Drake still
alive still is a big supporter of the
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
and he proposed a way to think about the
problem of is there life to think about
the question is there intelligent life
elsewhere in the galaxy so he found he
has what's called an equation it's not
really an equation it's an
organizational it's an organizational
tool for our ignorance it's really what
it is okay so what do you do here's how
you do you start off you see how many
stars in the galaxy it's like several
hundred billion pick a number four
hundred billion okay what what fraction
of those stars have planets okay it
might be maybe it's half okay okay so
you take half all right and what
fraction of the stars and planets have
planets that are in the zone around
their star where you can sustain liquid
water right his life onward as we know
it required over to an order you want
the planet to close otherwise your water
evaporates too far away it freezes right
right
in the right place Goldilocks is happy
ke go okay so you know so now you ask so
each one of these is a term in the
equation okay it's a fraction it's
essentially a fraction so you have
number of stars in the galaxy what
fraction have planet what fraction of
planets in the habitable zone the
Goldilocks zone what fraction of those
in the Goldilocks zone have life what
fraction of planets in the brown star in
the Goldilocks zone have life that has
achieved intelligence okay what fraction
of those around the planet in the red
and the Goldilocks zone and achieve it
tells that has achieved technology got
you those are the planets in the galaxy
that we might have a conversation with
using our radio telescopes and those are
the planets in the galaxy that one day
visit us and make us their pets yes
precisely so so in that equation over
the years we've we've sent up telescopes
of orbiting telescopes and spaceborne
telescopes that have gotten that have
improved our estimates for what those
fractions are I got and not all of them
were equal you know evenly known as each
other and the very last one is that the
last couple remain uncertain what
fraction of planets have life what
fraction of planets have intelligent
life what fraction of planets with
intelligent life have technology those
are completely unknown and you can just
express your bias in what those
fractions are 100% is it 1% 1/10 of 1%
and so if you do this even if you take
pessimistic numbers you you get huge
numbers of planets with technology left
over in the galaxy because you start
with it's such a large number be
starting with a huge number to begin
with a huge number right and my greatest
you know you know I've been known to
call out movies if they mess something
up that they shouldn't have messed up ok
may have heard about Dino that I know
that personally ok I know that firsthand
in the movie contact right which is all
about contacting life Jodie Foster
there's a scene
Larry Makani was she at Matthew
McConaughey just before their first kiss
she expresses her passion for the cosmos
and says to him
if there were a hundred billion stars in
the galaxy and they move a little closer
and only one and a million of those had
planets they get a little closer and
only one in a million of those with
planets had life and only one of the
million of those would life had
intelligent life that still leaves
millions of planets to explore no yeah
you can't divide a hundred billion that
many times by a million right it doesn't
work that way the odds of doing that are
the same of me kissing Jodie Foster or
Jodie Foster
kissing any man that's a different show
so true
so so that's hurt that was the movies
homage to the Drake Equation that's if
they didn't happen to get that one right
so in answer to John's question the
Drake Equation is unaffected completely
by our technological advances and what
we now know about the unifying the last
three terms remain completely uncertain
exact because we get to find another
planet with life so we can't do
statistics on it and and clearly if we
don't know one with life we don't know
one with life with civils that's
intelligence right we're an technology
exact right so but the chances our buddy
okay John chances are they're out there
yeah yeah okay they've already observed
earth and concluded there is no sign of
intelligent